>>> PAW PATROL!
>> AS MAYOR OF ADVENTURE BAY, I
HEREBY PRESENT THE PAW PATROL
WITH THIS MEDAL OF BRAVERY FOR
STOPPING THAT OUT-OF-CONTROL HOT
AIR BALLOON.
WITH YOU PUPS ON PATROL, OUR
CITY IS IN GOOD HANDS.
>> DON'T YOU MEAN GOOD PAWS?
>> HA HA HA!
>> ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
I'M CITY COUNCILMAN
HERB TANGIER.
MAYOR GOODWAY HAS PUT ALL OUR
LIVES AT RISK WITH HER PAW
PATROL INITIATIVE AND I SAY IT'S
TIME TO VOTE HER OUT.
FACT!
THIS MAN FIRED ALL OF OUR CITY'S
POLICE OFFICERS, FIREFIGHTERS,
AND PARAMEDICS, AND REPLACED
THEM WITH A GROUP OF SIX TALKING
DOGS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I THINK THAT WAS A BAD IDEA.
AND I'M NOT ALONE.
LISTEN TO THESE CONCERNED
CITIZENS.
>> I WAS EXCITED ABOUT THE PAW
PATROL AT FIRST.
TALKING DOGS WHO KNOW HOW TO FLY
JETS AND DRIVE?
GREAT.
BUT IT'S BECOME CLEAR THAT SIX
DOGS CANNOT PROTECT A CITY
ROUGHLY THE SIZE OF SAN DIEGO.
>> CRIMINALS AND LOW-LIFES ARE
FLOCKING HERE BECAUSE THEY KNOW
THERE'S ONLY ONE COP PATROLLING
OUR STREETS AND IT'S A DOG!
>> AND THERE'S ONLY ONE
FIREFIGHTER, ALSO A DOG.
SO IF THERE'S TWO FIRES AT THE
SAME TIME?
SOMEONE'S GETTING SCREWED, I
GUESS?
WHO IS IN CHARGE OF THIS
ORGANIZATION?
A CHILD?
>> YES!
THE PAW PATROL IS RUN BY A
10-YEAR-OLD BOY NAMED RYDER.
WHO IS THIS KID?
BEATS ME!
AS FAR AS WE CAN TELL, HE HAS NO
PARENTS AND DOESN'T GO TO
SCHOOL.
BUT MAYBE THAT'S FOR THE BEST,
BECAUSE WITH ALL OUR TAX DOLLARS
PAYING FOR A LITTLE COCKAPOO'S
JET PACK, WE NOW HAVE THE WORST
SCHOOLS IN THE STATE.
THIS IS MY 17-YEAR-OLD SON.
HE CAN BARELY READ.
>> I CAN READ, I JUST DON'T KNOW
WHAT SOUND VOWELS MAKE WHEN
THEY'RE NEXT TO OTHER LETTERS IN
A LINE.
>> MAYOR GOODWAY, THIS IS ALL
YOUR FAULT AND YOU NEED TO GO!
>> FACT.
OUR CITY'S COVID RESPONSE WAS A
NATIONAL DISGRACE.
WHY?
BECAUSE SIX DOGS WERE IN CHARGE
OF IT.
>> FACT.
CHASE THE POLICE DOG'S ONLY
WEAPON IS A NET.
QUESTION, HOW IS A NET GOING TO
HELP IF A LUNATIC ON BATH SALTS
IS EATING MY FACE?
ANSWER?
IT WON'T.
>> FACT, MARSHALL THE FIRE DOG
IS MY FAVORITE ONE.
HE'S THE FUNNIEST PUP BY FAR AND
THE COOLEST BY A MILE.
BUT I DON'T THINK HE COULD CARRY
ME DOWN A FLIGHT OF STAIRS
BECAUSE HE AIN'T GOT NO HANDS.
>> FACT, I ALSO LIKE MARSHALL
THE BEST.
HE'S SUPER BRAVE AND HIS JOKES
NEVER MISS.
BUT DO WE FEEL SAFE?
NO!
LISTEN TO THIS ACTUAL 911 CALL.
>> PAW PATROL ARE READY TO ROLL,
THIS IS RYDER, WHAT'S YOUR
EMERGENCY?
>> MY GIRLFRIEND, MAN.
SHE'S NOT WAKING UP!
HER EYES ARE, LIKE, ROLLED BACK.
I THINK SHE'S OD'ing, MAN.
>> UM -- PLEASE HOLD.
♪ PAW PATROL ♪
[ DIAL TONE ]
>> UNACCEPTABLE!
AND THAT'S NOT THE ONLY
EMERGENCY THAT PAW PATROL'S
BUNGLED.
JUST ASK MY SISTER.
>> I WENT INTO LABOR EARLY.
I WAS ALONE AND CALLED 911 FOR
HELP AND TOLD THEM MY WATER
BROKE.
SO THEY SENT ZUMA, THE WATER
RESCUE DOG.
HE DIDN'T UNDERSTAND WHAT WAS
HAPPENING AND SAT THERE CHEWING
ON HIS UPPER BUTT WHILE I GAVE
BIRTH ON MY KITCHEN FLOOR.
>> DISGRACEFUL!
BUT IT GETS WORSE.
>> RECENTLY MY WIFE WAS IN A
TERRIBLE ACCIDENT.
AND WHO CAME TO BREAK THIS
EARTH-SHAKING NEWS TO ME AND MY
CHILDREN?
A BULLDOG IN A HARD HAT.
AND MIDWAY THROUGH TELLING US,
HE STARTED DOING THAT SCOOTING
THING DOGS DO WHERE THEY PUT
THEIR HIND LEGS UNDER THEM AND
DRAG THEIR ITCHY ASS ACROSS THE
FLOOR.
ENOUGH IS ENOUGH!
>> MAYOR GOODWAY, THE NUMBERS
DON'T LIE.
ZERO SEX CRIME UNITS IN OUR
POLICE FORCE BECAUSE THE PAW
PATROL AND THEIR 10-YEAR-OLD
BOSS DON'T KNOW WHAT SEX IS.
AND ONE.
ONE CHANCE TO TAKE OUR CITY BACK
BY VOTING "YES" TO RECALL
MAYOR GOODWAY IN NEXT WEEK'S
SPECIAL ELECTION.
LET'S MAKE OUR VOICES HEARD AND
GET MY WIFE OUT OF OFFICE.
>> PAID FOR BY CATS.